♪ ♪
>> Greg: DONALD TRUMP
UNLEASHED HIS MIDTERM MESSAGE
INSIDE OUR NATION'S HOTEL
DOORMAT, "USA TODAY."
PREDICTING THAT DEMOCRATS WILL
TURN IT INTO VENEZUELA WHERE THE
CURRENCY IS PRINTED ON
PERFORATED ROLES.
TOILET PAPER IS A RARE COMMODITY
THERE.
NEVER SHAKE HANDS WITH THE
VENEZUELAN SOCIALIST.
IF WILLIAM DIVAN WERE DOING
COMMERCIALS IN CARACAS, HE WOULD
SAY NOW IS --
IT'S GOTTEN SO BAD THAT ZOOS
HAVE BECOME A SIZZLER FOR THE
STARVING.
DEMOCRATS SEE THIS AS PROGRESS.
DONALD TRUMP HIT ON THIS LAST
NIGHT.
>> President Trump: YOU DON'T
HAND MATCHES TO AN ARSONIST AND
YOU DON'T GIVE POWER TO AN ANGRY
LEFT-WING MOB AND THAT'S WHAT
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BECOME.
THEY WOULD TURN OUR COUNTRY SO
FAST INTO VENEZUELA AND
VENEZUELA IS NOT DOING TOO WELL.
>> Greg: THERE IS THE M WORD
WHICH SHOULD NEVER BE USED TO
DESCRIBE THREATENING HORDES.
>> ISN'T MOB BEHAVIOR?
NO.
PEOPLE WHO ARE UPSET AND ANGRY
WITH THE WAY THE COUNTRY IS
GOING AND THE POLICIES --
WILL YOU LET ME FINISH PLEASE
BEFORE YOU JUMP IN?
>> Greg: SOMEONE NEEDS A
TIMEOUT.
TRUMP SAYS THAT DEMOCRATS LURCH
TO THE LEFT "EVERY SINGLE
CITIZEN WILL BE HARMED BY SUCH A
RADICAL SHIFT.
VIRTUALLY EVERYWHERE IT'S BEEN
TRIED, SOCIALISM HAS BROUGHT
SUFFERING, MISERY, AND DECAY."
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU DESTROY
PROSPERITY?
YOU VACATE A COUNTRY AND ELECT A
BERNIE.
WHO WANTS TO COME HERE IF HERE
IS WORSE THAN THERE.
IF ONLY THERE WERE EXAMPLES OF
PEOPLE FLEEING LOUSY PLACES THAT
ONCE WERE GREAT BEFORE LEFTISTS
TOOK OVER.
OH, YEAH, VENEZUELA.
I THINK WE HAVE THE DEMOCRATS
SLOGAN FOR 2020.
ZEBRA.
IT'S WHAT'S FOR DINNER.
I HAVE NOTICED, JEDEDIAH, THAT
TRUMPS MESSAGES TO LINK THE
DEMOCRATS WITH VENEZUELA.
KIND OF LIKE WHAT HE DID WITH
COOK DID HILLARY WHAT'S THAT GU
GUY?
SLEEPY EYED CHUCK.
>> Jedidiah: YOU WERE CLOSE.
IT RESONATES.
HE HAS A WAY OF SAYING THINGS
THAT'S VERY RELATABLE AND THEN
HITS HOME.
ONE THING THAT STRIKES ME AS
DEMOCRATS LIKE TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES AS PRO-CHOICE ON
ABORTION OF COURSE.
THEY MAKE THE ARGUMENT OF
PRO-CHOICE.
AND EVERYTHING ELSE, THEY ARE
ANTICHOICE.
LOOKING AT WHAT HE WROTE, I WAS
THINKING THE DEMOCRATS DON'T
WANT TO GIVE PEOPLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CHOOSE DOCTORS,
JEWS WERE PART OF HEALTH CARE
THEY WANT.
THEY HAVE SOME AUDACITY CALLING
THEMSELVES PRO-CHOICE.
I KNOW THAT THEY LIMIT IT TO
ABORTION BUT IT'S INSANE.
THE POINT NEEDS TO BE DRIVEN
HOME, WHY DO YOU TRUST
BUREAUCRATS TO DO A BETTER JOB
FOR YOURSELF THEN YOU CAN DO?
BECAUSE GOVERNMENT IS NOT GOD.
THE LEFT LIKES TO TREAT
GOVERNMENT LIKE IT'S A DOER OF
GOOD AND THE PUBLIC SERVANT.
IT'S JUST BUREAUCRATS THAT SIT
IN ROOMS AND MAKE REGULATIONS
AND LAWS.
WHEN IT COMES TO YOUR HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING, DON'T YOU WANT TO BE
IN CHARGE?
>> Greg: NOT ME.
I WANT PEOPLE TO MAKE DECISIONS
FOR ME.
JUAN, I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ONLY
HOPE OF THE MIDTERMS IS
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT
ABOUT 20-SOME ODD DAYS FOR
SOMETHING TO HAPPEN THAT WILL
MAKE US FORGET THE KAVANAUGH
MOMENTUM.
>> Juan: I THINK THE BIG ISSUE
HERE AND IT TOUCHES ON SOCIALISM
IS HEALTH CARE.
I THINK THAT IS, JEDEDIAH, WHAT
PEOPLE ARE UPSET ABOUT.
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE IS THE HIGH COST OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS, THE
VIABILITY OF THINGS LIKE
MEDICARE, AND SOCIAL SECURITY.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S AMAZING TO ME
BUT ACCORDING TO THE POLLS, YOU
HAVE 70    70% OF AMERICANS WHO
SUPPORT MEDICARE FOR ALL.
SINGLE-PAYER.
SOMETHING LIKE OBAMACARE, I'M
SURE ANY FOX VIEWER REMEMBERS
THAT OBAMACARE WAS TERRIBLE.
NOW IT HAS THE MAJORITY OF THE
SUPPORT OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
>> Greg: MAY BE BECAUSE THEY
FEEL LIKE THERE'S NO CHOICES
LEFT.
WHEN SOMETHING STICKS AROUND FOR
A WHILE AND I KNOW THIS BECAUSE
I'M DESCRIBING MYSELF, PEOPLE
JUST GET USED TO IT.
>> Jedidiah: NEVER GET USED TO
IT.
>> Greg: JESSE, INTERESTING
THAT DONALD TRUMP PENNED A
COLUMN IN THE USA TODAY.
PEOPLE AT HOME UNDER THE AGE OF
30, IT'S A NEWSPAPER.
IT'S KIND OF LIKE YOUR PHONE
EXCEPT THE STUFF ON YOUR PHONE
IS PRINTED OUT.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS MEAN, WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT USA TODAY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT.
HE DOES HAVE A GIFT FOR MAKING
BIG, BOLD CONTRAST.
HE IS SETTING THIS UP, AMERICA
RESERVES VENEZUELA.
CAPITALISM VERSUS SOCIALISM.
GREATNESS VERSUS MISERY AND IT'S
NOT JUST A GOOD MIDTERM MESSAGE,
IT'S A GOOD GENERAL ELECTION
MESSAGE.
ONCE THE DEMOCRATS GOT THEIR
CLAWS INTO HEALTH CARE, NOT
GOING TO STOP AND LISTEN TO WHAT
THEY SAY.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT CAPPING
CEO SALARIES.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT
GUARANTEEING HOUSING IS A RIGHT.
THEY HAVE TALKED ABOUT UNIVERSAL
PRE-K, UNIVERSAL COLLEGE.
IN CALIFORNIA THERE EXPERIMENT
AND WITH GUARANTEED INCOME.
CARBON TAX.
THERE'S A LOT OF SOCIALIST IDEAS
THEY ARE KICKING AROUND WHICH
ARE VERY DANGEROUS AND IF THE
DEMOCRATS GET A HOLD OF ANY
LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT, ESPECIALLY
THE ECONOMY, THEY ARE GOING TO
SLOW DOWN THE BOOM SO BIG, WAGE
GROWTH IS GOING TO SLOW DOWN.
INVESTMENTS ARE GOING TO SLOW
DOWN.
ENTREPRENEURSHIP'S ARE GOING TO
SLOW DOWN.
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY DANGEROUS.
IT'S A GOOD MESSAGE GOING INTO
THE MIDTERMS.
>> Greg: DANA, I KNOW YOU HAVE
SOMETHING YOU WANT TO SAY.
DO YOU THINK CNN GOT A MEMO
ABOUT THE MOB?
THE M WORD.
>> Dana: IT'S NOT JUST CNN.
IT'S ACROSS THE BOARD ON THE
LEFT BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS THE ABILITY
TO MAKE THE CONTRAST AND HE HAS
THE LEFT ON DEFENSE.
THEY ARE ON THEIR HEELS.
YOU HAVE THIS IDEA, DEMOCRATS ON
EVERY SHOW OR SOCIAL MEDIA, IT'S
NOT A MOB.
WE ARE NOT SOCIALIST.
WE ARE NOT FOR ABOLISHING I.C.E.
THERE IS NO PROACTIVE MESSAGE
THEY CAN GET ACROSS BECAUSE HE
ALWAYS HAS THEM RESPONDING TO
HIM.
HE IS ALREADY SETTING UP 2020.
BASICALLY IT'S AMERICA VERSUS
WHAT DO YOU WANT TO BE?
AMERICA VERSUS SOCIALISTS.
IT'S A GREAT CIVICS AND
ECONOMICS LESSON.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN HISTORY,
OVER 50% OF THE WORLD'S
POPULATION IS MIDDLE-CLASS OR
HIGHER.
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE.
DIDN'T HAPPEN WITHOUT CAPITALIS
CAPITALISM.
WE DIDN'T REALLY HAVE A CHANCE
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: I THINK CAPITALISM IS
GREAT.
I WAS AT A CEREMONY AT A YOUNG
WOMAN CAME UP AND SAID SOMA
PEOPLE ARE DOWN ON CAPITALISM
BUT THE REALITY IS IF YOU
INVOLVE NOT JUST PROFITS,
QUARTERLY PROFITS, BUT YOU START
TALKING ABOUT STAKEHOLDERS,
EMPLOYEES, WORKERS, INVESTORS,
IT HAS MADE US RICHER.
I THINK THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE HIGH COST OF
DRUGS IN THIS COUNTRY IN THE
HIGH COST OF -- WE PAY TWICE AS
MUCH PER CAPITA AS ANY COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD AND YET WE HAVE
30 MILLION PEOPLE WHO ARE
UNINSURED AND WE KNOW IF YOU GET
IN A BAD ACCIDENT, CAN BE
CATASTROPHIC FOR YOUR ECONOMIC